có hoài đồng tiên hoài, có hoài hệ không?
Lại các quán thân nhất.
Tiên hoài xích khoẻ là tài cơ bỏ đầm.
Để anh chúc anh chỉ chúc mạnh khoẻ là đồng tiên.
Để vụ thấy được cái gái chỉ của cái xích khoẻ.
Nếu như một điều, vệ trong xúc khoẻ của bản đặt là mình ra trong cái bị quyết bẩy hai.
Vậy để trong xúc trong vong vào từ lúc của trong vụ mẹ.
Trời đi lúc xích ra đi học trở thành biểu, trở thành người càng thuận, trời đi lúc mất đi.
Tất cả được trong xúc.
Tình nhân đây ở tôi như vậy, đầy yêu.
Các mắt thành ra chỉ cũng có đồng tiên ở gần nữa mình không trở trong trong xúc khoẻ.
Tăng cơm với cái tệ giục tệ thào, giữ giống gặp đi,
mỗi người hãy tựa bắt xí của chính bình để xây dịch của nước để tàng khoẻ mạnh.